okay there are some homework problems
with the exercise outside
they're actually inside they won't be
necessary to follow the lecture but
they will definitely be useful
to continue following
let me
start with the definition
of netflix
it was defined by valiant
let's start with the matrix for
simplicity i'm going to take square
matrices and
matrices and
we want to reduce the rank of
a
to some value some target value
on
okay so that minimum number of changes
is from the rigidity of
the matrix a for target rank
r and we use this notation
for that it's the minimum number so
this notation again is the number of
non-zero increase in a matrix
overall such matrices c which we call
the change matrix
so that when you add the change matrix
the rank
becomes at most off okay
so the least number of changes
that you can make to the entries of a
so that its rank becomes atmospherity
what's a an easy upper bound
on
this number
it's essentially a trivial exercise and
it's the first exercise in the problem
shape
so for all a
and all your combined matrices for us
you can show you only need to change
you take some rv or mine
and then change everything the
complementary minor and you can make
sure that the rank
is at most off so that's an easy upper
bound
you know what about lower bounds
okay so
valiant himself proved
and this proof is actually we'll come
back to this if the field is infinite
then a generic a
will have
as much as minus r squared rigidity
we'll actually review this and for
finite
fields again this is an exercise
and you can show
for most a
it's some constant times
apart from a log factor
this is optimal so for
almost all matrices we actually know
that the rigidity is about
n minus or point t square so what's the
challenge here what's the
main question about matrix rigidity so
the main question
is to find
explicit matrices
so i mean when i say explicit matrix i
really mean here
an infinite family of matrices and here
i mean
a sub n and epsilon and delta or some
constants
i will not formally define what explicit
is but
the most the nicest definition would be
a should be polynomial time computable
in some reasonable model of computation
again you know i will not
spend too much time there um but we will
see examples where we would consider
matrices
to be explicit and examples where we
don't consider them to be explicit
enough
for the purposes of complexity so so why
do we want to
answer a question like this i mean in
some sense
we know the exact answer essentially for
almost all matrices
so the motivation for
posing this question very valiant comes
from
arithmetic complexity so let me
let me do that here
so the goal is to prove
lower bounds on
arithmetic complexity and i'll define
the model in just a second
of computing the linear transformation
given by the
matrix a and the model is very simple
the only operation that we do is compute
linear combinations
so if you say u 1 and
u 2 are some linear combinations of
inputs that you've already computed
in one step you can compute sorry
let's say these are scalars alpha 1
alpha 2 you can compute v
which is a linear combination of these
two things this is only operation that
we
that we do so in order to compute
this linear transformation given by a
you start with
your input vector x1 through xn then
take linear combination of combinations
of a bunch of those
and take linear combinations of those
guys
and so on okay and eventually you will
you will get your y so let's say this is
y
okay so that's a circuit
the input at the bottom and the
computation flows upwards
and um the size of the circuit
is the number of edges in this graph
or the number of wires if you think of
these as y's this is a plus one
okay and scalar multiplications are free
these are scalar multiplications
and we are only counting the linear
combinations that are done
and the depth of the circuit is the
length of the longest
input to output path so is the longest
chain of
dependencies in this computation
so that's it okay
so questions
all right so um now it's easy to see
that for all n by n
a
you can compute this
in depth order log n
and size order n squared
a big complexity question which is still
into that
the big complexity question is find
interesting linear transformations a
that require um
logarithmic depth and super linear size
simultaneously or rather super linear
size
actually i mean sorry let me rephrase
this so
it's less ambiguous
that cannot be computed
by depth login so we don't
sacrifice depth but size we want
to be linear so small circuits
of logarithmic depth and you want to
show that such circuits cannot compute
some explicit linear transformation so
that's the lower bound question that
we would like to solve linear
transformations obviously are
extremely important they come up all the
time in
computations one of the interesting
linear transformations of course is the
fast fourier transform
where you actually don't require size
order n squared but order n log n
but is that optimal so that's one of the
fundamental questions
right so fourier transform can be
computed using
n log n size and logarithmic depth
um you would like to know whether it's
conceivable to have a linear time
computation
for the fourier transform and if you
want to disprove that if you want to
prove that it cannot be
done so efficiently one way to
solve that is to address the rigidity
problem
so the theorem that variant proved and
that's the motivation
here is that if you
show that the rigidity
of a matrix is large enough
for target rank constant fraction of n
then this linear transformation
cannot be computed
in log depth
and linear size
okay so it's kind of a
serum reduction to the depth to the
circuit
sorry yeah that's the sort of reduction
to depth to
the the theorem in some sense yes i mean
um yeah actually yeah i wasn't going to
prove the theorem but intuitively
um the proof is some kind of a depth
reduction now that you know depth
reduction has become such a major theme
in complexity
we can think about the proof of value
proof also is a kind of depth reduction
basically um a graph theoretical meant
that he uses
from a previous result is
if this graph this linear circuit is
size order n then you can identify a
small number of
vertices which if you pull them apart
from the graph meaning that you take
those vertices and all the adjacent
edges
then the graph shrinks in the sense that
every input of
output path that avoids those vertices
is actually
short okay so that's kind of a depth
reduction
but the number of nodes that you need to
remove to shrink the depth
is actually quite small and that gives
us
the rank bound here so by removing a
small number of vertices
um and therefore you sort of route your
computation
through those vertices and the rest of
the computation
flows through very short paths and if it
is a short path you can just expand it
into
a tree and that's the depth 2 circuit we
are talking about
and that depth to circuit because it's
sharp meaning the depth is now instead
of
order log n it is some delta log n
or some small n of delta and that's how
you get n to the one plus delta
okay a depth to circuit of size plus
delta and that's
sort of the rigidity those are the
changes that you're making the depth two
strike it is the changes
okay so it's very fast i i i
don't want to get into the details but
basically
the idea of the proof is to reduce the
depth of the circuit by removing a small
number of vertices
and use those small number of vertices
and
the residual circuit to get a lower rank
approximation
of the original matrix so that's the
intuition
all right okay so
from now onwards let's just focus on
this question this just
focus on proving lower bounds on
rigidity of
matrices so what would be a good
candidate for proving
a lower bound position here
now or just like here
point a
okay so that's that's our central
question
and would like to get as close to
answering that as possible
so what would be a good candidate matrix
for which you hope to prove that
changing its rank to r let's consider a
generic or general r
um although eventually we are interested
in this value of
r um so that you know
you will require a lot of changes to
bring down tonight
and
okay so the whole bunch of android
matrix is depending on how you
so i'll write this
i don't know i'm used to writing this
with the exercise denoting
because i know a lot of people are used
to
writing them as columns that's why i'm
writing this explicitly
all right now
what do we want these excise to be if
the matrix wants to be expressed if you
want
things maybe it's pretty explicit okay
so
um one interesting
choice for x i is
x i being all
positive reals
why am i choosing that
the reason i'm choosing that is if you
of course if x i are generic everything
i'm going to say is true but
let's choose x i to be positive real so
that i can actually put numbers here
all right so if i do that then
the interesting property is that such a
random matrix
has all minors
non-zero every determinant every
sub-determinant of every size of this
matrix
is non-zero so it kind of looks very
robust
because if you want to reduce the rank
to
say r you pretty much have to kill
every r plus one by r plus one sub
determinant
and you have to do this for every value
larger than
r however of course you can do that for
r plus one then you have done it for
everything but
anyway so in some sense a matrix
that has um so these are called totally
regular
these are class
totally regular matrices
so these are matrices
for which all submit squares of matrices
obviously all squares of matrices
are non-singular so this looks like
as robustness
you can get all right so what can we say
about
matrices that are totally irregular
so now i want to prove
you know it's actually let me not state
the theorem here it's actually
easy to arrive at the theorem by just
looking at this problem
so
so if i have this matrix where every r
plus 1 by 1
if i want to hit every r plus one by r
plus one
sub matrix i need to
choose enough so so the question then is
this
um and that's
how many changes do i need
just combinatorial argument i'm not
doing any algebra or linear algebra here
how many changes do we need
to hit every r plus 1
by r plus 1 submatrix
right that's the question so that
clearly gives us a lower bound on
rigidity
no i mean if r is small enough then
many sub matrices let's say r is one
over 100 then
many little matrixes but just kidding
yeah but i mean there will be many small
squares of matrices
all over the place
and these are combinatorial matrices
right yeah yeah yeah i mean
yeah these are just i mean when i say r
plus one by rs or plus one sub matrix
i'm
picking some i 1 through y or j 1
through j
r and some i 1 2 j 1 through j i plus 1
r plus 1 is for r plus 1 and i'm
looking at the intersections of those
rows and columns
all right so
so where we're going to answer this is
to actually
use the combinatorial
problem so we are going to think about a
the the entries of a are you know
as a bipartite graph
but other coordinates of it so you're
going to look at a bipartite graph
with words this one through n
through n and you put an edge between i
and j
if that's an unchanged entry
so if you changed
s entries
this graph let me call this g
g has n squared s
edges and now we are asking
how many edges and and what is the
squares of matrix
a squared sub matrix uh corresponds to a
bunch of i mean r plus one
vertices here and r plus one minus is
here and if it is not changed
this would be a complete bipartite sub
graph right no changes
in that minor plus one by r plus one sub
matrix means you have a complete
bipartite graph
so so let me use a symbol here let's
call this m
so how large are how many edges
do we need another
the other way down
so what's the maximum number of edges
in g to avoid
n r plus 1 by r plus 1
complete bipartite
so this is a well studied question
it's called cern the
problem well in general not just
um or i mean
uv completed by bipartite graph and
there is a
an upper bound known on the number of
number of edges that a graph can have
while avoiding such complete bipartite
graphs
so the maximum number of edges in a
bipartite graph when you forbid
a an r by r r plus one by
plus one completed by conjugate and
that's a
known quantity and so
this is at most
right n squared minus is this number
and that number has a formula uh
well but there's an expression of a
bound that
we don't have to worry too much about
but i'll write it down
we're talking about an r plus one by r
plus one so it will be something like
r to the 1 over r plus 1
this is actually not so critical for the
computations but i'll write it
in minus r this is critical
times n to the 1 minus
so roughly speaking it's and
so you have n squared right um
potential edges so if you sort of think
about this as
not too big compared to the fraction of
m so this is like something like n to
the 2 right
n to the 2 minus 1 over r plus 1. that 1
over r plus 1 is the loss i mean
in the exponent that that's it
and
so what does that say r to the what r to
the one over r plus one
so it's really a small quantity
okay so if you just use this bound
you know bound you will conclude that
s is at least well i mean you have to
you
put some restrictions on also that so
that you know these
calculations make sense but i'll just
omit all of those
and uh say
something like this sorry i mean we're
interested when
r is equal to epsilon times n right yeah
yeah yeah that that will be fine yeah
well that i mean that will be fine in
the sense that will not uh
violate these calculations but it will
be uninteresting
sorry or
log squared some you know some large
enough r but
not too large
essentially you get omega n squared
divided by
hot and the logarithmic factor okay
so obviously
um right
in the matrix those
entries that are changed correspond to a
fiber diagram unchanged unchanged
increase
yeah unchanged increase okay and now
so you want to this rank condition how
does it translate
complete microsoft what do we do exactly
oh you want to
you want to hit every r plus 1 by r plus
1 sub matrix
um or in other words
that's already a different question
because hitting is not
oh yeah that's not okay so that's not
sufficient that's necessary yes okay
of course
no no i mean it's not i mean okay
otherwise we would have like
partnered with the bottom line yes it's
not unfortunately yes yeah
so um yeah so exactly so all i'm doing
in this
board is try to estimate a lower bound
on the number of
entries that you need to change in order
to have
at least one change in every r plus one
by r plus one sub metrics
i'm sorry no no
absolutely yeah
not leave actually no no not leave you
you want to
not have any perspective
that's forbidden our first one the first
one is
so is the left hand side is that like
the column index and the other is the
grow index or it doesn't matter that's
related to
is that the relationship you're starting
with the complete graph
right so and and and complete bipartite
graph
and you when the problem starts before
like how's that graph related to this
question
you want to kill you want to touch each
size r plus one minor so you want to
kill enough edges so that every r plus
one minor is touched
the left side the left hand side the
left hand side vertices correspond to
those and the right hand side vertices
correspond to columns
right and now if there is
no change in
entry i j you put an edge between vertex
i
invert mixture okay
so every non change corresponds to
an edge and since we don't
want to leave any r plus 1 by r plus 1
sub matrix untouched
okay you don't want
any r plus one by r plus one complete
bipartite graphing this graph
okay but if you insist on that condition
in a complete bipartite graph
it cannot have too many edges and this
number
gives you the maximum number of edges
that it can have
and therefore that number has to be at
least
the number of non-changes you have
n square over r since three now yes so
the gain here is likely
um n squared over r uh for
for these matrices if you use a
probabilistic argument yes
uh for some specific matrices but for
arbitrary totally regular matrices n
squared over r
probably okay you can just divide it
into there can be
omega
yes yeah yeah yeah actually you're right
i mean n squared over r
in fact one of the homework problems is
that n squared over r is actually very
easy to prove for most matrices
um but this is the best known so i want
to yeah and
and in some sense these are the matrices
for which you expect
almost maximality
no in fact yeah that was going to be the
open question that i was
going to mention at the end yes yeah no
it's not
so okay what's the conclusion here
so
the conclusion is for these matrices
the rigidity is omega n squared over our
log n over essentially so
you kind of put conditions
in r so for reasonable range
of target rank or
you get that bound
so that boundary is far from what we
want
but unfortunately that's the best we
know so far
for explicit matrices and there are many
such matrices so here is one example and
there are a couple more examples
in the homework for example the cauchy
matrix
whose increase
function matrix is y
why do you require r to be less than n
over two
oh i'm just approximating uh rather
estimating n times
n over r i have something like n times n
over r and that
is when i say that's n squared over some
never r epsilon comes n for any epsilon
less than one but you get the same
yeah yeah sure sure i mean
yeah i mean i i could i could hear one
minus epsilon
and constantly change that okay
and the most interesting matrices from
the point of view of explicitness and
also from the point of view of
applications
are matrices or finite fields
and derived from error correcting codes
and
i will again you know i will not spend
time on that
um one of the homework problems is that
so uh because this is the best result
known so far
on finite fields let me just state that
so um so now consider a finite field of
q
and the generator matrix of an error
correcting code
is a k by n matrix
according theory they write vectors
as row vectors so we'll stick to that
notation
so the code given by g
is
u transpose g so the raw space
of this
so this is clearly a subspace
okay and the distance the minimum
distance
of the cord is
the minimum weight of a code word
okay so
what what this means is that in this
subspace if you take any
two vectors c1 and c2
they differ in at least this many so
let's call this d
this many coordinates let's
encrypting code okay
maybe many people know this already so
so such a code is called n k
d so this is d okay the
code and um
using algebraic geometry algebra
geometric course achieve codes of the
kind
n n over 2
is a highly non-trivial result
okay and now by
converting g into standard form
i can write g as identity followed by
matrix a
and if such a matrix g
has good distance such as this
then you can prove that the matrix a has
almost the kind of property that we have
for totally regular matrices
in other words um
sorry what is what yes n plain d again
um k is this dimension no but
k is the message length that is the
codeword length d is the minimum
distance
so um a has the property that
every
two t by two t sub matrix
has rank
at least t for t greater than
this
will be d plus one okay
so
so um so error correcting codes good
error correcting codes
give you good matrices these sort of
you know totally regular kind of methods
not exactly because the rank is not
full but constant fraction of the full
but that's still okay and the same
arguments will
work and you can prove that and
therefore
the conclusion is that there are
explicit matrices
namely matrices coming from these kinds
of error correcting codes
for which we can prove a rigidity lower
bound of this
and square over time yes
in particular a generic matrix is
totally right
yes
it's much worse it's much worse because
there is a
there's an order in the denominator
epsilon n
yeah if r is epsilon n this is trivial i
mean this is this this is linear
does it say hola
that's the interesting values of target
angle
we want to consider
yeah so um formally
if the minimum number of
sorry the minimum weight of a vector in
the row space non-zero vector in this
course space the weight being the number
of non-zero coordinates
okay i mean that's also equal because
this is a vector space
to the distance meaning the number of
coordinates in which they differ
between any pair of vectors in this
space
and that's that's why it's called the
minimum distance if you take
any two vectors in this subspace they
differ in at least
d many coordinates
all right so maybe another question is
what assumptions do we need oh yeah i
mean there are
there are some standard assumptions x i
and y j should be distinct
and x i plus
y j should not be zero for any
other than that you don't need anything
all right so um
so for finite fields that's
unfortunately the end of the story we
don't know anything better than that
and that's kind of those are
very nice matrices but the bound is
quite uninteresting
okay all right so now
what do we do i mean where are we
right
so one thing that is relatively easy to
check
and well known is that you cannot
improve this number just by
combinatorial arguments
so if you if you want to hit every r
plus one by r plus one sub matrix
the bond that i wrote down is optimal
okay but actually there is a an even
worse
conclusion um
which is a result due to brilliant
himself
so there exists totally regular matrices
of a
can be computed
in log depth and linear size
which is in some sense um
bad news if you want to prove lower
bounds but good news when
you want to compute linear
transformations um
in particular this means that
the rigidity of those matrices is small
so total regularity this condition which
we thought is quite natural and nice to
prove within the robots
actually turns out to be too weak to
prove the kinds of lower bonds that we
need
for valiance criterion i will not prove
this
theorem but again it follows from
a graph theoretic construction follows
from
super concentrators which are
some interesting graphs constructed from
expander graphs
uh again i will go into that super
concentrators of
linear size and logarithmic
or actually i should say
reconstruction also
from here to computing this is actually
resulting in distressing
okay so this condition
of matrix being totally regular
is is actually not good enough and
i don't know any other property that
that we could sort of use for a whole
class of matrices
to give explicit matrices like this like
code matrix or
you know any of these matrices
on rigidity so what i'm going to do now
is to consider
results where we don't get lower bonds
for explicit matrices we get stronger
bounds but
we sacrifice on explicitness and we use
more algebra
than you know what we have our rather
you know we haven't done any
thing in argument so far so
then simple combinatorial orders
so it's almost time for the break
so let's take a break and then when we
come back
after a short break we'll
look at some algebraic arguments for
such matrices so x i are now generic
sales about
switching to complex numbers
yeah i mean of course you would expect
such matrices to have
high highest possible or at least almost
as high
volatility as highest possible but we
don't know how to prove
so that's actually one of the big open
questions and let me
split it right away um
so yeah unfortunately even such a
there's a question
we don't know we don't know the answer
so what i will do now
is prove a much weaker theorem
and you will realize that the proof is
actually quite simple and
it's not
okay let me just say let's go over four
four small elements
okay so so
it's constant picked once and for all
the epsilon yeah yeah okay
just smaller yeah smaller of constant
epsilon
yes
small enough something yeah all right
okay so so at least asymptotically
for small enough rank
we know that it has you know
quadratic rigidity
and the way we prove this is to uh
i'll sketch the proof because i'm
probably going to run out of time to
do everything i want to do um is a
notion
that the shoe prints small and ski
i have defined in the context of proving
second lower bounds but
that turns out to be useful also to
derive
rigidity lower bounds at least in some
limited sense
and and this definition um
for this definition we will just think
about
sequences of numbers complex numbers and
i'm running out of symbols so let me
just
actually let me sorry
let me use notation and just say a
uh so you're given a sequence of complex
numbers m
complex numbers and in our case a will
be a matrix and we just write the
entries of the matrix in some order okay
so that's why
it's okay to do this and now what we are
going to do
is consider
okay take some distinct t
elements of the sequence multiply them
that's a complex number think of that as
a vector for the rationals
and then look at the span okay
so let's put a symbol there
so some d
a t is the dimension
for rationals
distinct
criterions
okay so it's
just the number field dimension of the
number field generated by these theta
books
okay now why is this interesting um
so one little lemma that you can easily
prove
is if
a let's say now i'm thinking of it as a
complex matrix
it has
rank r then this quantity it's
very easy to prove is at most
and are sorry
this is not this is t
r is the rank
squad well the proof is actually
uh it's easy to it's easy to see um let
me just
so since a is of rank r you can write
that as
an n by r and an r by n matrix and
therefore
essentially these aijs
are inner products between rows here and
columns here
which are they're only n are such
variables here and there are such
variables here and so if you
if you write these triples
in terms of as as as linear combinations
of tuples from this matrix and this
matrix
you will get that the rightmost pattern
it's a very simple
counting argument so that's that's it so
so if low rank matrices have a small
shupes malinsky dimension that's
the main point and now it's very easy to
prove this
so how do we prove this
suppose c is the change
matrix
then um yes
so you define this dimension for a
vector
a is
yeah so these these are just the entries
of the matrix written in some order
n equals n squared yeah this sum is my
okay okay so i've taken it as a vector
uh size of c
is the relativity
and so we have we know two things well
actually we know at least one thing
that um uh
the dimension this this dimension of v
minus c
so so rank of v minus c or v plus c
is atmosphere so this
guy we know is at most and not
just useful
okay now we want to prove a lower bound
on this using the genericity of the 1 1
matrix
okay so now in this matrix we made a
bunch of changes
actually let me call this s so that i
don't have to write the whole thing
yes and um so change matrix that
achieves this and this is variability
okay so uh there are s changes
that i made into this matrix
and therefore by a simple averaging
argument
n over two rows
have at most
two so the average number of changes per
row is s over m
this is the total number of changes the
average number is also n
so if you take twice the average you
have
at least
all right so now um
i'll just ignore the elements
that have been changed now i still have
n minus
two s or n powers
elements are unchanged
in these rows each of these rows
right and so
so if i just take one
from each of those m over two
rows one of the powers of x r's
right they will all be
linearly independent over q
okay
so what we know
uh i'll write n over two now
is at least that many
you take any one of the unchanged
entries
in one row and any one of one change
increase in the next row and so on
and you can do this up to n over 2
and all these monomials are going to be
linearly independent
that's it so you just compare so here
you put t equals n over 2 so d
v minus c n over 2 is at most
if i could get n or plus
n over 2 n 2
squared and if you just compare
you get s is at least
n minus m c r square divided by
so this is some constant based on how
you approximate this
um and you know this
anyway so basically it is n times n
minus
constant times r squared and that
squared is what's killing us
rather i mean that's where sort of comes
from this and i
don't see how it could
anyway so that's kind of all we know
about
generic 101 matrices
actually we know a little more but i'll
come back
yeah yeah we not realities but we we do
know some
special in fact i'm going to write one
next
so using the same essentially the same
ideas
the problem here is that
the problem here is that you need to
because because
in each row you have powers of the same
variable
you cannot take you cannot mix
elements from the same row so you can
you can generalize this argument and i
will not prove it
proof idea is very similar to this but
you will do better than this
because you have more freedom in
choosing these triples
and that theorem is this
so let p be this matrix
square root of t i
p i j or distinct primes
then you can show that
something like this
so this definitely meets valiants
criterion
okay of
something like this
okay
a very similar argument now you know
earlier i could not take
t to be larger than n because because of
this
um because i need to pick one
element from each row but now
this matrix is sort of you know very
random looking and there is no
you are just throwing a lot of quadratic
irrational numbers into the matrix and
that's really all
you're doing and and the same argument
allows you now to choose larger t
and if you choose logic e and using
similar computations
you can get better lower bound on the
rigidity and you actually get a
quadratic lower bound for
r epsilon m
it does not quadratic super linear
yeah actually it does also employ
nearly quadratic you can actually derive
n squared over log and lower ones for
this matrix
but not through rigidity criteria so
there is another path to proving lower
bounds on
linear circuits not going through
rigidity but directly applying these
kinds of dimensional arguments to the
circuits
and then you get n squared over log n um
but
yeah so so you do get certain lower
bounds um
but you also need to take the quadratic
yes what if you don't take square root
what if you just put the prime is then
is it oh
well at least in that case this proof
doesn't work
this proof definitely doesn't work but i
don't know if
there is a way to prove yeah
um so i mean you can you can play with
this a little more and get
you know interesting or you know
slightly stronger lower bounds but let
me stop here and move to
algebraic geometry
where you can do even better but then
you know every time you do a better
lower bound you get a better lower bound
with rigidity
about rigidity you lose something like
here i mean you lost
you lost the explicitness because these
are not rational numbers and these are
you know you really need them to be
rational numbers for the whole proof to
work
and this is why it is not as
satisfactory as
you would like i mean as interesting as
we would like from a circuit complexity
point of view
yeah i mean yeah so if you can prove
that if you truncate something continues
to hold
i don't know what that something is and
rigidity can be proved that would be
fantastic but i don't know how to
how to do that i mean i don't know how
to get
some kind of a rational approximation to
this proof
or you know the arguments in this book
um yeah it could be very interesting
yeah i mean we were ideally we would
like rational approximations of two
polynomial precision but
forget polynomial precision any finite
precision
rational approximations to these
matrices can
prove that they are rigid i mean we
believe they are but i don't know how to
prove it
i don't know a technical approach how i
can prove that
all right so now uh since um
actually i should have left here anyway
so let me
now
look at rigidity from a
from an algebraic geometry perspective
and what i'm going to say will be
very elementary and there are better
experts in the audience on algebraic
geometry
than me and there are actually
much stronger results than what i'm
going to say
that have been proved so i will
just give a brief introduction so
all right so now let's
we know very little so this is more like
an open direction than explaining what
we know
um
okay first of all
the easier thing to look at
is the variety of matrices
ah sorry actually no jump in your head
sorry um
okay that's a
well studied or depending on who you
talk to
study object
and it's
really a variety
defined by the ideal inr
where inr is the
r plus 1 by r plus 1
minus
open n by n x
okay so so we know about
i mean how to define low rank matrices
in algebraic geometry language now let's
try to do this for rigidity
and that's not hard to do so let's use
red and r s
to be the matrices a complex matrices
such that
the rigidity of a for target and r is at
atmospheres
okay so when these a matrix
in this set um it is in this set
if a can be written
so if you take a
so there exists a change matrix a such
that
rank of a minus c
is at most of foreign okay
so that's why you put it here and
what is c c is
um c has at most
s non-zero entries
so this also we know let me write that
as
l because it's a linear space
l and pi will be the set of all matrices
c
such that non-zero increase
i mean support non-zero increase of c
or index by
and uh well okay so that's it
okay so a
is in this set if if and only
there is a thing
okay so it's easy to understand
matrices of small rigidity in terms of
these two values
and for so ah let me
okay so let me just for notational
convenience let me in fact it's actually
useful
okay all right so by making changes
in the pattern pi you're able to reduce
the rank to
r okay so now
this is easy to understand um what is it
you took the matrix a and and if you
think about this
an entry here um is
rather the variety correspond i'm sorry
uh oh my goodness
okay
okay you took a matrix here and when you
subtract a matrix from here you
got into a rank so so if you consider
a matrix x
in r and if you consider
set of extra variables indexed by pi
so the minus r plus 1 by r plus 1 minus
of x plus p
phi are 0.
yeah yeah a plus t t pi is equal to x
p plus you're mixing notation
yeah i am because the minors of r plus 1
minors of a
are 0 not a plus t pi um no not
a a plus c actually a is not yeah
a is not in there right
okay yeah so um okay so since
i'm actually running out of time and i'm
trying to compress
let me just say this so the way to think
about
the risky closure of this car okay so
this is what we want to understand
right is you take
the idea and then you eliminate
so this idea is on all n squared
variables
um what i was trying to say is
eliminate variables indexed by pi
out of this then you get an elimination
idea
and the variables here are
variables that are outside outside this
pattern
and the main claim is that
it's actually yeah it's not even a lemma
but anyway yeah
so re and are
pi with closure of that
is the variety defined by this
elimination idea
and intuitively this should be very
clear okay
so what we are doing is um
when you take when you take a matrix
in the variety defined of the zeros
closure of this
the difference between that and the rank
r matrix is exactly the matrix
whose support is pi okay
and if you eliminate the variables in pi
pi is the one that i mean the
the matrix c is the one that that
that's existentially quantified so in
some sense
in order to understand the matrices
for which there exists a c satisfying
this property
you would like to eliminate the
variables corresponding to c
and get an algebraic condition on the
entries of it
and that's exactly what we are doing
okay so
so for every pattern pi if you eliminate
the corresponding variables you get a
whole bunch of
elimination ideals for different
patterns and
the varieties corresponding to these
different patterns
of the elimination of these different
patterns are exactly the speed closures
of these
relativity varieties okay and in fact
there are irreducible components
of the regulatory variables of
the zenith closure of this okay so
that's kind of the geometric picture
now what do we do with this um
so one thing that we can trivially do
is try to understand what kinds of
polynomials live in this
because um if you if you remember the
previous
argument if you know something about the
degree of polynomials
on which a matrix should vanish if it
has small rigidity
then you could construct matrices which
don't
satisfy satisfy such a polynomial
equation
okay so so one approach would be to try
to get degree upper bounds
on polynomials in the elimination ideals
of these flow rank matrices yes
oh i mean as long as the size of the
pattern is the same like
it would be the same no no it depends on
how pi
no the pi is gener there's a kind of
generic dimension
but is if you have say more than n
minus one changes in a row if you have n
minus one changes in a row that the
dimension drops for example
n minus r and minus minus r
yeah so
there is a basic dimension that it can
drop
actually yeah right right
yeah but i don't know if there i mean if
there is a systematic way to
explain the drop yeah there's a theorem
called
chinese lemma right that enables you to
calculate the sphere
infinitesimally and you
just look at the intersections of the
feminine spaces and they're non
generic than the dimensional block all
right
okay yes
remember that okay so
so one thing that that's well known
already
is some very
exponentially large upper bounds
okay so the effective measurements
shows that i will not state the theorem
there are several
several results polar
with various conditions and there is
of paper that we use you can find
for the others so there are several
results but instead of stating the
theorem let me just say what it
implies for us
all that implies is that there exists a
polynomial g
in the elimination ideal
degree of g is at most very bad
into the 2n square
of 4 m square let me put a constant
some small constant see okay
so so once you have such a degree bound
then you can construct matrices which
don't satisfy polynomials of
that degree
and so if you construct a matrix a
which has roots of unity
rpg here are primes that are all bigger
than
that number
then
this matrix uh
yeah so you have to use a bunch of
parameters here which i didn't specify
but
you know the main thing that you you
need to argue here is that
um the size of pi
is i mean then the pattern is
at most n minus
rather actually with respect exactly
minus r squared minus one so one less
than the maximum rigidity
so so if you if you consider the
rigidity varieties
for one less than maximal rigidity
then the elimination ideals will have
polynomials
of degree at most that and then you can
construct matrices that don't satisfy
such polynomials and that will give us
know that
okay now this is
um this gives you some sort of a finite
bound on the on the
algebraic degree of elements in the
matrix a but it's still not interesting
for the same reasons
and in fact even worse than the previous
matrices because of this
93 so um
since i'm almost out of time um actually
i
wanted to say something about the more
recent paper
that uses much more sophisticated
algebra geometry
but all four authors are here and
you can we can get a lot more accurate
and a lot more intuitive
description let me know if i'm
spelling your names right
i better look at him before someone gets
sick
i don't get offended it's okay
since the authors are here you don't
need to spell their names yeah
okay all right
okay so they actually
uh take a deeper look at the algebraic
geometry of
the rigidity varieties and like jm was
saying
you know much more refined view
of of these varieties
and several
several properties general properties of
the polynomials
are generators of the of these ideals
are given
and some of the conclusions interesting
concrete conclusions
um i'll just say this
is that caution matrix and generic
vendor
matrix well these are all generic okay
maximal rigidity
there are many more results i'm just
stating these as concrete lower bounds
on rigidity
maximal rigidity for r equals 1
for r equals n minus 1 it's trivial for
the cos n minus 2 it is known
so for a generic quantum one matrix we
also know that for
n minus 2 you have maximal vegetation
okay um yeah unfortunately i
i can't say much more about it partly
because i don't understand me
but partly because i'm running out of
time um
but let me state an open question given
you know
all these crazy matrices that we have
seen
in the last few minutes which seemed to
have
very high rigidity beating
the bound that valiant required for this
criterion but somehow we are saying they
are very interesting
and how do we formalize
the other interestingness of these
matrices and how do we sort of
go you know somewhere midway between
uninteresting and interesting
right so i already said something about
generic quantum and maybe that's one of
the open questions i was going to say
another open question is construct
matrices of
epsilon n in
only dimensional number of fields
so we are not asking for explicit
in the sense of exactly deterministic or
polynomial time com
computability but but just put the
entries of your matrix
in a number field of polynomial
dimension
so if this is exponential dimension we
know how to do it if it is exponential
in
n squared we know how to do it
so i don't even know how to do it in
exponential in n
but poly dimension would be very
interesting then
in some regular sense
uh for i don't know non-computational
sense
these could be considered interesting
matrices
because then you have in some sense you
know when do we when do we want to think
of a matrix being explicit we want to
have
a polynomial size representation of that
matrix
polynomial size representation on a
finite computer
and if the number field is a polynomial
dimension then you can
represent it the entries can be
representing
polynomial so that's the reason why i
think this would be interesting
okay so as as a candidate for this
you know one of the matrices that i
would like to think of
is this which is sort of
you know again you know one by one
matrix
but not very generic
not very explicitator where these omega
i's are peer through pi
primitive roots of unity
lt and pi are the first or polynomial
points okay first 10 times let's see
i mean they should not be too big
so that's a i mean i think this is sort
of you know
ideally what we would like to do really
is if all these omega
so the fourier transform matrix
transfer matrix as i said is one of the
most interesting matrices for which
you should try to prove radical or bond
because that would imply that the
fourier transform cannot be computed in
linear time there you have
just one root of unity primitive load of
unity and the
the other omegas are just powers of it
so i don't want matrix
uh but generated by powers of the same
multiple of unity
so now um i didn't write it i
raised it but if you throw in large
roots of unity
all over the matrix we know that it has
large variability
and so this is sort of intermediate and
this also belongs to the class of under
one matrices
which we would like to prove relativity
for the degree of the field extension
would be something like
would be exponential different studies
yeah yeah so yeah so that's why you know
this is the question i would recommend
this is sort of a candidate matrix but
you know any matrix
which is in exponent less than
exponential n squared number field
i think would be progress and
polynomial dimension i think would be
really really interesting
i don't know if it has any implications
to circuit complexity but it's a
clean mathematical question
all right i will stop there
oh good question so actually um
tensor rigidity was defined and studied
but i know only one paper
doing that and i don't
quite remember the results they are
of course considerably weaker than what
we know for rigidity
and they do have some consequences to
complexity and that's really why they
were defined
and at least in the context that they
were defined
um they wanted rigidity over
gf2 which is actually the most difficult
field
um you would want to follow when you you
could think of approving lower bounce
and widget
so um yeah
or gf2 we have no idea two
the finite fields that we were talking
about where we had even the n squared
over log
n squared over our kind of lower bound
are for finite fields of
some small constant but not maybe 49 or
something
yes so um how low would the degree
of this g have to be to have
consequences for complexity 30
oh like if it was brought down to
polynomial and then
yeah so i mean i think if you brought it
down to polynomial then this question
could be answered but i don't know if it
has any direct consequence not to my
knowledge
to circuit complexity
it may be possible i haven't worked on
deriving a consequence but i have a
feeling that it might
be possible to derive consequences to
certain complexity
maybe it could be mentioned that some i
mean this
matrices you study they look very
similar to
this problem well people tried for many
many
decades to prove lower bounds for the
explicit volume we said just one
variable
there was this pioneering paper by
strasse in 73
where he came up with he had a
polynomial where the coefficients were
just square root of the crimes
yes of unity and then
and i think it's very similar also in
terms of technique now this is the
rigidity problem it's
related to yeah yeah but i think
the techniques are very similar and so
it seems that we get stuck
always more or less at the same time
what was the variety in question the
stress in the problem
the variety i mean the variety that is
this was just
say this look at the set of polynomials
in one variable
that multiplicative complexity of most
are
it's not so it doesn't have such a nice
description as here
i mean here the the parametric
description of the variety is very easy
and it's right
question of finding the equations which
is not so easy right maybe the other in
the other problem
right is much more complicated
looks so much simpler
still
okay so so maybe the problem is is the
elimination ideal so
now if we could completely understand
elimination i mean
well but you see this is a very general
theorem i know but this is a very
special the original idea you're
starting out with this very very special
and
one should use special techniques to get
a sharper result
the problem here where we lose the
information is
the elimination idea no
we don't know it exactly so we just know
there is some g
of me this is that but even now it's
better
it may be possible to understand the
polynomials
in this i mean the ideals of these
varieties more directly
instead of trying to refine
the process of elimination for these
particular varieties
i guess that's kind of what you're
saying i mean i think
i think the geometric intuition for
for the rank varieties and these are
essentially the projections of the right
uh the lower major space varieties of
lowering matrices
might actually give you you know more
direct information and it may be
possible so i don't know
well i mean again you know these are
determinant ideals and detrimental
ideals have been very well studied but
i have you know from you know from my
conversations with a few experts
it's not clear at all whether you can
improve the bound
on the district rebound for determining
five deals
it's also worth mentioning that i i
don't know if there's co-authors but at
least one of the authors is
the rosen also found uh very explicit
equations
in a completely different context for a
completely different problem
but it the it solves this problem also
but again there's still no consequences
here yeah some very interesting
polynomials there
but you know just like what we did it's
there's no consequence yet
but he has found i don't know who the
other co-authors are friends here i am
yeah so okay yeah i mean i think i think
you know if
i mean like they did for r equals i mean
the polynomials that they have for
these two ranks are very nice i mean
they and you know once you see those
polynomials it's
fairly easy to see that those
polynomials are not going to be
satisfied by generate 21 matrixes
and they're fairly clean and it would be
nice to
get such polynomials for larger banks
or you know ranks away from small
constant
and away from it i have no idea
what to do
sorry yes
i mean in every one of them you have a
polynomial like this and you know
no such degree polynomial is going to be
satisfied by this matrix
yeah so you do you do have to um
look at all patterns so i raised it but
the rigid variety is the union of
these variations overall
but even if you have all these
polynomials
yeah right now the only the only state
the property of the polynomials we are
using is their degree form
so i mean since we i mean i have no idea
how to write those polynomials down like
they did for other values of
the rank we only use the degree pound
so it would be nice i mean yeah i mean
definitely if you can
get more structure of the out of these
polynomials
then maybe you can construct nicer
matrices
if you consider a random matrix plug
yes yeah yeah
so that's one of the homework problems
that's the last homework problem
um the i mean basically
leads you to the proof um over the real
numbers yeah
uh a random zero one matrix plus minus
one matrix yes
uh omega n squared so that's why
you know constructing given zero one
matrices of high rigidity
is not hard if you are willing to settle
for
random matrices so you really need
some effective way to produce an
infinite sequence of matrices
and that's why explicitness needs to be
properly defined
even for zero one matrices it's like you
know
expander graphs are attracting chords
where again it's easy to produce
random objects nice objects but
much harder to produce explicit things
any more questions for this question you
could do it
over the rationals or over zero one
matrices with that
oh i see
i'm not sure i don't know i mean
basically i don't know how to interpret
this polynomial
dimension of a number field in a
computational sense
i mean i i believe there is probably
something that one can do but i have not
done that
yeah that's a good question actually
that's uh yeah i mean with some small
national
um yeah even then i don't know i mean
even then
i really don't know how to have a
computational interpretation of that
um but yeah so
so in some sense this is this is a
weakening of what you were asking right
this is a much weaker question
all right so we can bring the speaker
again